[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau
numéro du skycho le magazine qui raconte
toutes les aventures économiques du
territoire de saintquanttin en ieline
alors cette nouvelle édition elle sera
notamment consacrée au Mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui se
déroule tout le mois de novembre ce
rendez-vous est incontournable c'est
notamment l'occasion de comprendre cette
économie mais aussi de rencontrer les
acteurs qui lapportent et d'ailleurs
parmi eux et à l'association envie à
trpe c'est là que nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui et dans ce numéro vous
découvrirez comment envie s'engage dans
cette économie sociale et solidaire mais
avant d'en parler voici le sommaire du
skycho la software Rpublique présente sa
talent académie le 23 octobre les
membres de la software République
dévoilai les premières réalisations et
l'ambition de son écosystème
collaboratif de formation la talent
Academy moi de l'esss installé à trappe
depuis 2012 l'association en s'engage
depuis des années dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire
rencontre réparer au lieu d'acheter
grâce à SOS accessoires basé à morpa SOS
accessoir est devenu le leader européen
de l'autoréparation et de la vente de
pièces détaché dans ce numéro plongez
dans l'univers du Do It Yourself mais
tout de suite découvrez la talent
académie de la software
[Musique]
rublique je vous remercie beaucoup
les membres de la software République se
rassemblaient le 23 octobre à l'école
2600 à Montini le breteneux ils y
présenter leur écosystème collaboratif
de formation son nom la talent Academy
ces ternes ne vous dis sûrement rien
alors pour commencer c'est quoi la
software rublique c'est une initiative
qui a été lancée en avril 2021 par six
grands groupes dasso système eviden
orange Renault group ST Microelectronics
et Thalès
leur but faire face au manque
d'ingénieur en France mais surtout au
manque de jeunes sortant de formation
scientifique le but de la soft publique
c'est finalement de faire ensemble des
choses qu'on n pas capable de faire tout
seul d'abord centrer sur des produits
des services donc des activités je
dirais d'ordre plus business et puis
finalement de manière assez naturelle
est venue la question des compétences
puisque pour créer tous ces produits on
a besoin de compéten software on s'est
rendu compte qu'on en manquait tous et
donc on a décidé de Sallier pour
également
euh augmenter je dirais notre tuyau de
de compéten dans le monde dans le monde
du software en faisant des actions là
encore en commun à ce jour il manquerait
près de 20000 nouveaux ingénieurs
diplômé en France selon le syndicat
STech ingénierie c'est là qu'intervient
la talent académie l'objectif est simple
susciter des vocation et attirer les
jeunes en particulier les jeunes femmes
vers le monde de la technologie et de
l'industrie pour ce pour ce faire la
talent académie articule son programme
autour de trois grands axes l'éducation
le recrutement et la formation ils
correspondent aux trois moments clés
d'une carrière professionnelle donc tout
d'abord l'éducation donc pour ce pour
cela nous avons créé le programme
Factory qui est un programme dédié aux
jeunes quand je dis les jeunes ce sont
les 15 20 ans donc dès le collège on va
à la rencontre de de ces jeunes pour
essayer de susciter des des passions de
voilà autour des métiers de de
l'ingénierie auprès donc des des jeunes
et en particulier des jeunes filles pour
le recrutement c'est la talent incubator
qui s'en charge ce programme
d'apprentissage est dédié aux 20-25 ans
qui sont à la recherche de leur premier
emploi et enfin la formation avec la
talent accélérator qui intervient en
cours de carrière nous avons le
programme accélérateur qui là est un
programme de formation continue dédié à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs des six
entreprises de la software Rpublique et
là nous avons comme objectif de former
40000 collaborateurs à horizon 2025 et
donc la talent academmie de softwire
rpubli est un pilier complémentaire aux
politiques de ressources humaines qui
existent dans nos entreprises et qui va
permettre d'atteindre cet objectif
ambitieux parmi ceux qui ont intégré ce
projet il y a Victor Verdet apprenti à
l'école 2600 et membre de la talent
incubator il fait partie de l'équipe
software rubl de chez Renault group pour
lui intégrer ce programme a été une
chance il s'agit du premier écosystème
collaboratif de formation mis en place
par de grands groupe concrètement ça
nous on est convié à des à des
événements on est convié à des à des
voilà des conférences des des formations
voilà rencontrer les d'autres alternants
et d'autres
experts d'autres écoles qui font partie
de la talante Academy donc ça
démultiplie encore plus notre réseau
futur et à côté de ça ce qui ce qui est
super intéressant c'est que la software
République nous nous propose du du
matériel et bah des experts pour venir
enseigner et aussi pour qu'on puisse bah
s'exercer cette initiative est inédite
en France et en Europe il s'agit du
premier écosystème collaboratif de
formation mis en place par de grands
[Musique]
groupes
former et accompagner des personnes en
difficulté ou éloigné du marché du
travail c'est l'ambition de
l'association envie et c'est d'ailleurs
grâce à cette initiative qu'envit trpp
est devenu un acteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire pour en parler je
suis aujourd'hui avec Éric gastino vous
êtes directeur d'envie bonjour bonjour
alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter l'association
envie oui donc l'association envie c'est
une entreprise
d'insertion qui a pour spécialité la
réparation et la rénovation d'équipement
électroménager son activité économique
elle sert de
support à l'emploi la formation et
l'accompagnement vers le retour à
l'emploi durable de personnes qui
étaient au chômage depuis longtemps donc
comme je disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
acteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donc quelles sont les
initiatives que vous mettez en place
justement pour être dans cette démarche
le social et solidaire ça se traduit par
ça en fait c'est que on va inclure dans
le monde professionnel des gens qui
étaient en rupture avec le monde du
travail donc il y a cette cette notion
de d'accompagnement et de
solidarité j'aiz envie on pense que la
valeur le travail dans toutes ces
dimensions collective dans le contenu de
des formations dans le contenu
intellectuel et manuel du métier va
permettre à des gens de se reconstruire
de reprendre
confiance de réintégrer aussi un un
collectif un groupe de travail pour
ensuite être armé lorsqu'ils vont sortir
d'ici pour travailler dans n'importe
quelle entreprise et concrètement vous
avez des exemples comment vous voulez
former les accompagn ici alors ici on va
les former au métiers qu'on pratique euh
donc c'est la réparation d'appareils
électroménager mais c'est également des
métiers logistiques ça peut être de la
logistique et la manutention en entrepôt
dans ce cas-là on va leur faire passer
des cassè par exemple pour apprendre à
conduire des engins de manutention ça
peut être des métiers de livraison de
livreur installateur chez nos clients
puisque dans nos prestations on livre et
on installe t nos matériels donc sur ces
métiers là ces métiersl vont servir de
de support
à la professionnalisation si je peux
dire ça comme ça des personnes qu'on
accompagne ceux qui arrivent ici qu'on
embauche pour certains les plus jeunes
parfois n'ont jamais travaillé et donc
n'ont pas la connaissance des codes de
l'entreprise et donc découvr ce que
c'est que la vie professionnelle et puis
d'autres plus anciens ont eu des
accidents de parcours et là on leur
remet le pied àétrier et on on leur fait
reprendre confiance dans le travail
aussi parce que c'est parfois des gens
qui ont été abîmé par le travail
justement donc vraiment le le les
métiers que l'on propose pose ici
technique logistique vente
également doit donner un bagage
professionnel une forme technique sous
forme de de de relationnel qui permet
d'outiller nos salariés pour les ensuite
pour qu'il s'envolent d'ici et qu' qu'
le qu' qu'il fassent preuve de la même
confiance et du même professionnalisme
ailleurs et lorsque leur projet
professionnel s'éloigne de ce que l'on
pratique ici mais on trouve des
solutions pour financer des formations
qui se rapprochent de leur projet si
vous voulez travailler dans les espaces
verts par exemple ben on va essayer de
de trouver des formations de ce type là
pour des personnes qui vont rester
salarié chez nous mais qui vont parfois
faire des périodes d'immersion dans
d'autres entreprises du territoire et
comment vous voulez trouver ces
personnes elles viennent directement à
vous ou comment ça se passe alors on
travaille en relation avec ce qu'on
appelle des prescripteurs sociaux donc
ça peut être po emploi ça peut être les
missions locales pour les plus jeunes ça
peut être d'autres structures de
l'insertion parac activité
économique voilà on a un certain nombre
de de partenaires autour de nous qui
nous proposent des candidatures ça peut
être aussi des candidatures spontanées
et on
va recruter nos salariés en parcours
d'accompagnement non pas sur une
compétence professionnelle he vous
l'avez bien compris mais sur leur
motivation à s'en sortir et leur
motivation et leur capacité à pouvoir
travailler donc c'est ça qu'on va
évaluer lors d'un ou plusieurs
entretiens et ensuite on va les les
employer dans le cadre de contrat à
durée déterminée d'insertion qui sont
des contrats de 4 mois qu'on peut
renouveler jusqu'à 6 fois pour une
période maximum de 2 ans donc dans cette
période là de 2 ans tout notre travail
va consister
à définir un projet professionnel pour
les
personnes lever aussi un certain nombre
de freins sociaux périphériques à
l'emploi ça peut être des problèmes de
logement des problèmes de santé euh des
difficultés comportementales euh voilà
c'est très divers chaque cas est
particulier et et et on va travailler en
même temps sur la partie professionnelle
et puis sur l'accompagnement social pour
ça au sein de la structure il y a une
personne entièrement dédiée à cet
accompagnement social et qui va
travailler avec des travailleurs sociaux
du territoire des références sociaux
pour faire progresser et faire
disparaître les difficultés majeures qui
les empêchaient de revenir à l'emploi et
donc vous avez un petit peu des chiffres
combien de personnes vous aidz chaque
année ou comment ça se passe alors
chaque année il a une quaine de
personnes qui passent ici il y a un
turnover presque de de 100 % chaque
année la durée moyenne d'un salarié en
parcours chez nous c'est environ 13 mois
et donc souvent parce qu'ils partent en
emploi avant la fin des 2 ans puis ceux
qui sont le plus en difficulté on a
tendance à les garder un peu plus
longtemps et donc au final sur
l'ensemble de la structure aujourd'hui
c'est environ 25 personnes en équivalent
en plein sur l'ensemble de l'année qu'on
va accompagner qu'on va remettre petit à
petit sur le chemin de de l'emploi et
c'est quel quelque chose qui fonctionne
combien de personnes ont retrouvé du
travail après ou en tout cas se sont
inséré professionnellement al oui c'est
un dispositif alors chez Envie attrape
comme dans l'ensemble du réseau national
envie puisque envie c'est un réseau qui
réunit une cinquantaine de structures
dans toute la France c'est un dispositif
qui fonctionne alors moi ma conviction
c'est que ça fonctionne par la par le
contenu métier de ce que l'on pratique
ici par la technicité et et le le le
professionnalisme qu'on essaie de mettre
en place donc chaque année c'est environ
80 % des gens qu'on accueille qui va
retrouver soit un emploi à la sortie
sous forme de CDD long ou de CDI soit
une formation qualifiante de longue
durée qui va leur permettre
d'approfondir leurs connaissances
professionnelles et depuis quand vous
faites cette démarche vous avez une date
ou pas alors ici l'activité a démarré en
2012 donc on a fêté nos 10 ans l'année
dernière donc ça fait un peu plus de 10
ans hein donc vous faites le calcul
c'est c'est plus de 200 personnes qu'on
a remis en emploi depuis la création de
l'association euh et le réseau en viille
lui existe depuis 1984 avec une première
structure à à Strasbourg donc ça fait ça
fait 40 ans maintenant pratiquement que
le réseau envie existe que ce dispositif
là existe qui
mélange savoir-faire professionnel et
technique sur ce qu'on appelle
l'économie circulaire donc la le
réemploi la la seconde vie d'appareil
électroménager et et cette activité là
qui sert de support à notre mission
sociale et à à l'inclusion et la
réintégration de personnes je dirais
dans la société hein c'est à travers le
le monde du travail mais c'est dans la
société de de manière générale donc
c'est un modèle qui fonctionne bien qui
était très innovant qui est toujours et
qui se réinvente presque chaque jour je
dirais bah merci beaucoup erry merci à
vous merci alors on le rappelle en
novembre c'est le Mois de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et pour cette 16e
édition 5tin en Evine se mobilise
l'agglomération vous propose notamment
de découvrir et de rencontrer les
acteurs cantinois de l'ES grâce à
plusieurs événements vous les
retrouverez dans l'agenda à la fin de
cette émission mais tout de suite je
vous invite à entrer dans l'univers du
TW It Yourself avec SOS
[Musique]
accessoir bonjour je suis Olivier de
montliveau le fondateur et dirigeant de
SOS accessoir SOS accessoir c'est une
entreprise que j'ai créé il y a 15 ans
maintenant et qui est devenu en quelques
années le leader en France de
l'autoréparation et de la vente de
pièces détaché pour réparer ces
appareils
électroménager aujourd'hui nous
expédions des milliers de commande
chaque jour et nous aidons des dizaines
de milliers d'internautes avec nos
compun nos tutos nos vidéos à réparer à
entretenir leurs appareils
[Musique]
électroménager
c'est le fruit d'une expérience que j'ai
passé chez un précédent employeur j'ai
travaillé une dizaine d'années chez chez
Dary la centrale d'achat accessoire de
chez Dary et c'est là-bas que j'ai
identifié un besoin suffisamment
satisfait pour les consommateurs de
toutes enseignes l'obtention de pièces
détachées et d'accessoires justement
pour réparer ces appareils
électroménagés c'est très compliqué à
obtenir en magasin en SAV et il y a 15
ans on oublie un peu mais c'était les
débuts de l'Internet marchand et
internet est un moyen fantastique pour
identifier et se faire livrer dans des
bonnes conditions de fiabilité et de et
de délai une pièce détachée pour réparer
un appareil
éctrong au début quand j'ai commencé SOS
accessoir je n'avais qu'un salarié bah
aujourd'hui vous voyez on est à peu près
120 personnes chez SOS accessoir et non
pas chaque jour mais chaque semaine ou
en tout cas chaque mois de nouveaux
collaborateurs viennent rejoindre à la
société alors là ici vous avez près de
500000 pièces détachées qui sont
stockées c'est le plus important stock
de France de pièces détachées
disponibles livra en 24 he depuis le
lancement de SOS accessoires nous avons
aidé à réparer plus de 3 millions
d'appareils électroménagés et cette
année- làà en 2023 plus d'un million
d'appareils auront été réparés
entretenus grâce à SOS accessoir donc
c'est un million d'appareils qui
n'auront pas été rachetés mais qui
auront été réparés et au final qui
auront fait du bien à à tout le monde et
en premier lieu à la planète là vous
voyez lestable de colisage où sont les
opérateurs c'est par ce convoyeur
central quiarve dans les différentes
caisses de préparation toutes les pièces
qui sont préparées pour toutes les
commandes qui sont tombées sur le site
internet dans les heures qui précèdent
ou la veille le coliseur prend une
caisse il scanne la pièce il prend un
des cartons que vous voyez là sur le
convoyeur sur trois étages de de
convoyeur qui aura préalablement été
formé automatiquement par une formeuse
de caisse que vous devinez là-bas le
préparateur prend la pièce prend un
carton met la pièce dans le carton et
met ensuite le carton sur le tapis que
vous voyez le carton poursuit son chemin
il va passer dans différentes étape de
contrôle contrôle de scan code barre
contrôle pondéral on contrôle son son
poids qui par cohérence permet de
s'assurer que c'est bien le ou les bons
contenus à l'intérieur
photo et ensuite il va passer dans la
grosse machine que vous avez là-bas qui
est ce qu'on appelle une fermeuse de
caisse vous voyez que le collier est
ouvert selon le gabari du du carton il
passe dans l'une ou l'autre des
fermeuses de
caisse le colis est automatiquement
fermé il poursuit son chemin il passe
ensuite à l'étiquetage transport et
ensuite ça monte jusqu'aux différentes
gares d'expédition chaque gare
correspondant à un transporteur et
ensuite les palettes les Rolls les les
bacs sont ensuite chargés dans les
différents camions transporteurs et et
collectés une ou plusieurs fois par jour
pour être livré le lendemain ou le
surlendemain chez le consommateur ou
dans le point relais choisi par le
consommateur là vous êtes au cœur de la
production de notre chaîne de télévision
sur Youtube donc là on est sur la
production de de contenu vidéo c'est ici
que son tourne nos euh nos vidéos nos
tutos vidéos mais on fait la même chose
aussi en production écrit parce que les
deux sont très importants pour les
internautes et ce sont donc les équipes
internes de SOS accessoir des
techniciens électroménagers chevronnés
qui vont tourner devant une caméra avec
des cadreurs monteurs salariés de SOS
accessoires qui ensuite vont monter et
publier ces fameuses vidéos qui vont
aider les internautes à à diagnostiquer
et à réparer derrière donc là ici vous
êtes au cœur de l'atelier de réparation
SOS accessoires donc c'est un atelier
qu'on a lancé récemment et qui vient
clairement compléter notre offre
d'autoréparation maintenant ici à morpas
dans les ivelines nous faisons aussi de
la réparation pour proposer une solution
complémentaire alternative à nos
consommateurs alors la principalement en
local he bien sûr puisque c'est destiné
aux consommateurs qui sont dans les
evvelines donc qui apportent leur
appareil et qui en quelques jours se
font réparer à de très bonnes conditions
leur appareil gros ménager ou petit
ménager vous l'avez compris à SOS
accessoire est une société en forte
croissance en 15 ans chaque année nous
avons un niveau de croissance de 20 à 60
%. et pour alimenter cette croissance
pour passer ces différents paliers de de
croissance nous avons besoin de trois
choses principales des locaux on en est
à notre 5e site 4e déménagement
évidemment les hommes et les femmes qui
composent les équipes de SOS accessoires
je vous ai dit près de 120
collaborateurs de plein de métiers
différents et de plus en plus de gros
investissements mécaniques à it
informatique et d'automatisation demain
nous allons continuer à alimenter cette
croissance nous sommes devenus les
leaders en France et bien notre ambition
elle est très clairement de devenir un
leader en Europe d'autoréparation et de
vente de pièces et accessoires pour
réparer les appareils
[Musique]
électroménager on termine avec l'agenda
ce mois-ci ne manquez pas le Mois de
l'économie social et solidaire tout le
mois de novembre
50 ans en Eveline se mobilise et vous
propose de découvrir les acteurs ctinois
de l'esss à travers book des vidéos et
des rencontres la Semaine de l'industrie
du 27 novembre au 3 décembre 2023 plongé
dans le monde de l'industrie de
l'innovation et de la technologie
française la conférence du club climat
énergie le 28 novembre prochain de 9h à
15h rencontrer les entreprises et les
collectivités qui se sont adapté
notamment en termees de sobriété
[Musique]
énergétique
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78